[Aplausos]
né
o latitude como não é costas e sem chuva
eu tenho diz a sentença e estou josé
luiz lisboa na área da economia
eu gosto porque sempre eu sei que tem e
sempre ofício com isso aí tá fácil era o
jogo escola de alencar os meus primos
pensei que ela faz tudo que eu peguei
falam que eu quero fazer ginástica
eles também não durou muito e agora tem
mais de uma onda de que os jogos vão
levar os méritos de agosto em nova cruz
alta e também nos jogos porque o por
mais que faça eu nunca sofreu menos é um
começo de 2012 realizado por aí eu
comecei está em condição grave quanto em
apenas 57 ea minha paixão por este
acordo com o chefe e com ela disse eu
também
atualmente o terceiro nec é o sagrado
sido feito até quando souber é o marco
inicial de origem coreana que tem como
objetivo o desenvolvimento físico e
mental dos atletas têm feito tradicional
que você pensa a média de idade o fazem
de uma das artes marciais mais completas
do mundo nos tornamos um combatente
contato mas não se fez uma espécie de
coreografia né otan contra o cliente
imaginários realizadas defesa pessoal
quebra tabus e talvez a minha parte fina
que é o e cenário é este mote quando
juntamos várias artes marciais como
exemplo a capoeira como futebol enquanto
e fazemos mortais e acrobacias entre
outras coisas muito mais
o taekwondo além de aportes puramente
física foca também uma porta de metal em
atividade como por exemplo alguns
valores como ferida ou retirado e
apresentar-se que me ajudou muito ao
longo da minha vida eu aumentar em cerca
de cinco saídas de funcionários sendo
que a alta competição extraction claro
todos os dias
o restante consiste em dar ainda parte
física e na porta de metal do trailer é
se o que é o défice o rs é um
transformar a estrutura e foi a partilha
será que consegue dar aulas e também com
os árbitros adicionais
eu contei quando se ser claro muito
cuidado entrega no entanto enquanto como
sempre ter uma alimentação regrada tempo
domingo não posso faltar por trás de
todo esse cuidado de um atleta
profissional enquanto faixa através do
site e sim existem cerca de dez vezes
tem de gente cleide antes de atingir 100
de preto
depois tive é mais uma identidade eu sou
anna e atingir o primeiro é em 2013 e
foi também a sua envolve mais a série
ficou em choque
eu não é 2014 2015
falta sair o primeiro título europeu com
as empresas a entrar ele é pública
cheque é meu eu ia ficar muito mais
motivado e sabe conseguir falar em
quatro títulos mundiais o acto que é um
campeonato que junta o melhor esperar o
comercial graus celsius quente e claro
que sinto e foi nessa e em 2010 site
próprio com muitas hipóteses de ganhar
eu sou eu e só pôde ficar mais lento que
o eu consegui sair em dois dias
exclusivamente estranho com os anos e um
dia só competição
eu tô velho foi qualificado que é esse
evento é melhor pra que vocês vai acabar
eu fiz um poder mais difícil e aí e caiu
fica é como a dor piora nas costas e não
conseguiu vitória e fala diretamente com
os fisioterapeutas o presidente
confessou não queria parar mas eu sei o
que ativa o que eu não queria continuar
que não podia continuar a se respeitarem
filme recebeu sido campeão ao colo o
pacto não conseguia assim cheia de
lágrimas toda a gente olhar pra mim e
foi muito chato ter entrado humanitária
para isso e depois chegar lá e ver tudo
e própria mas acabaria por provocar as
contas se eu vou te falar completamente
estranho ficava nas costas milhões em
alguns problemas revela deteriorado - ea
competição tem cuidado mesmo online
dois meses depois com o trabalhador vai
ter que me parece é e deve ser resolvido
de aula e fica pior legal tem que ganhar
o grupo irão conquistar muito não sei
como está a acontecer foi atribuído ao
mau ao local era quase que meter o
convite projeto evento para curtir mesmo
assim o apuramento para o resultado e eu
fui tudo acontecer outra vez entrar ea
sua chamada z procurado do mundo através
da ponte que liga europa uma escala
muito mais rica e cheguei lá eu entro no
programa e ela começou a fazer o que eu
vi na minha vida nunca tinha visto tanta
gente junta provavelmente além de muita
gente muita gente bonita na última os
grandes lá câmeras para as pessoas que
dizem fazer tudo lá espalhadas que eu
nunca me senti tão nervosa assim imagine
o secretário com que ter uma tela assim
história é contada tecnológico junto da
minha cara que é o melhor canal
esportivo do mundo e eu estava muito
nervosa do galo já contratou o lateral
estava muito contente
portugal ganhou agora vou ganhar eu e
fui dei tudo o que tinha em mente no
crono de uma forma que vai ficar em
salvador mesmo assim é ótimo um diálogo
e no dia seguinte mais uma competição
onde a lopa e aí sim de tudo tinha tudo
que não tinha nunca aconteceu enquanto o
bayern conseguiu atingir o primeiro
lugar
a sessão que agora deve ser nas costas
quando você tem que jogar assim
depois que o chefe futebol e ir para o
trabalho por causa das coxas
nessa condição tem que o time entrou
voltaram com que mais acelerou de sair
do zero no final e fui campeão
atualizada de quatro títulos eo em 2018
está a vassoura e vai contar com a
conquista em quatro categorias
tradicionais 4 credíveis e três de
quinta é possível dado participar em
todas elas e conseguia pensar no nosso
primeiro lugar não como aconteceu
enquanto a mãe quer ver o mundial não é
e apesar de não ter continuado circuito
nacional que terminou em alta aqui na
ufc e guarani que também hora em que
você tira a melhor forma de todos os
cintos de água e todo este tempo fica lá
enquanto também tirou muito eu tudo que
eu faço parte por ter mesmo paixão e
também tudo que eu entregar me porque o
rendimento quando souber apesar de
considerar se á ainda não engrenou novas
até difícil tráfego lado e eu sou a
pessoa que não gosta da prova pertence à
noite planos milhões de idéias na cabeça
e saber que eu não estou sabendo que o
difícil é conseguir ficar concentrada
recentemente com um novo projecto que já
vou falar aqui nada só jantar aqui uma
coisa que eu acredito que se nós
quisermos fazer alguma coisa nós
conseguir eu com trabalho eu sou quem
quer ser e 95 custa muito eu cheguei a
casa todos os dias
é um dever ver o episódio da série com
um capítulo no momento quero me firmar e
resolver todos os drivers de saída de
fada
o cicv que entrou num curso que quero e
vou ter um bom futuro trata de um giro
as nossas prioridades mais que inspira
nossas prioridades e assumidamente gay
pessoa não tem tempo pra lá de tempo e
eu agora mais cento menos do que eu saí
com um projeto novo que pode portugal
não se ouviram falar
segundo a utilizar água pergunta aí
acabaram por realizar um mundial tem
gente como por exemplo a jornalista só
mais uma coisa que é mais difícil
conciliar o horário que também ocupa
muito tempo e só não fazer isso sozinha
lá eu e eu faço mais conhecido chef 5987
limitado em que eu entrei com as chances
de gol mas qual era dez vezes maior que
a minha filha eu comecei o start claro
mas ele vai ter que estudar mais o time
e não vou precisar muito mais tempo e
não estava conseguindo conciliar as duas
coisas é possível pra mim pode entrar em
uma escola nova que eu quero ver um
grande diante é só querer e ter energia
estava na final youzhny e reformas de
escolas terão simples vir que que não
devia ser assim eu lembro que uma vez
que o mesmo que estava a pensar que a
prioridade não estava a acontecer com um
europeu à frente grande diante eu tava
lá alguns mestres muita gente olha pra
mim e otimizá 85 cv que a eqüidade não
estavam certas resultado mas falta-me
estava tinha um significado muito mais
na escola e muito mais curto eo tático
irã no teste
a melhora do time quando mas faltava
remédio eu passei
me sentia muito sozinha e aposta nos
velhos ligou e eu não estava lá e disse
que não tinha muitos amigos na escola
era difícil e bateu firme mas felizmente
ele falou pessoas que me ajudaram muito
alguns dentro da escola mas também mas
nada muito fora da escola isso permite
um outro conseguia conciliar as duas
coisas e também mais recentemente
reservas podem para mim eu gosto de
acreditar que essa copa não só três de
trabalho a solo de sorte de ter
objetivos mas não trabalharam
nós também não gostamos atingir e vai x
um cliente só tenho tido sorte mas a
sorte vem com o trabalho nós criamos a
nossa própria sorte
daniela mais rápida ou panela mais na
internet
eu claro que ele mesmo já viram que nem
era natural de nosso envolvimento em
atividades mais mas temos que ver que a
vida só duas opções ou descer hoje por
mesmo em que seu nome foi apenas o
sentido religioso deixei de acreditar eu
mesmo quero acreditar que sou capaz
nós devemos sentir os dois é claro que é
normal sentir os dois e os inspire e os
20 fechando a tropa de choque de ver com
a letra definitiva e corda que nos
impulsiona a quadra estava com a fé me
ajuda na strike mais difícil da escola
foi acreditar que tudo ia virar em virou
e curioso não é que não tem medo
josé que eu pretendo mesmo outra passa e
nunca de que seja aberta entre o federal
que sempre quis e em vez disso trabalho
para fazer desde que segue sozinha
também não funcionar para ser servida à
população por mais que eu quero uma
coisa aconteça essa coisa não vai
acontecer não fizer isso eu estava
querendo ficar pior para eles e agora eu
vou passar um tempo no filme ela não
pode ser
assim eu quero uma coisa eu tenho que
trabalhar pra isso eu só sei fazer vai
ter muito com a gente não sabe muito
pronto como sabe uma coisa que eu
aprendi muito como treinador e aprender
ser é nunca perder uma oportunidade
oferece uma oportunidade
nós temos carga rápida essa atividade
pode ser só mais um neco pode ser obtido
foi embora minha equipe e quem é que eu
colocava por ser ao longo da minha vida
tudo muito que eu não saiba conversar eu
pesquiso que for preciso eu trabalho pra
trabalhar eu penso em jogar aqui talvez
eu nunca desisti e tenho sempre o menor
uma coisa que é que não consegui
eu não falei eu aprendi muito difícil
aceitar as eleições
eu tenho meu filho pra conseguir fazer
para conseguir fazer de tudo para
conseguir conciliar trás depois eu te
importas emitiu seu projeto é acreditar
possível mas nós quis fazer para
conseguir é uma chata que seja uma saia
ele zerou caiu está a entrar em detalhe
os colegas 155 às quatro da tarde
essa espera sentar livre tornaram 12
horas por semana mais ou menos nessa
terça feira isto aqui é assim eu faço eu
quiser contratar ninguém lá foi para o
que importa é que se pode fazer tudo
isso é ternura e com quando ele está no
território muito ao longo da minha vida
e eu vou acabar queria fazer aqui uma
frase que eu gosto muito que é lançado
bem e falhou é ali onde eu falei skills
não arranjar desculpas porque todos
temos tempo aliás todos temos o mesmo
tempo meio dia tem 24 horas você tem 24
horas por dia todo sem moral de viva voz
ou para aproveitar ou para dispensar
mais uma vez que esse tempo a pessoa já
não há volta lá é tarde pra quem sabe
por exemplo como aproveitado por exemplo
eu espero aproveitar meu tempo
espero que vocês tenham
obrigada e só pelo convite e obrigá-lo a
manter o hábito